this is our first viewing an actual
first viewing in a while with next month
because I remember seeing the trailers
for this and thinking wow this and I
have no interest yeah horribly blend
this is hop I know nothing about it
ex-ira messing a few commercials and
that kind of disappeared and then people
were asking me to do it on this - agree
but every time they asked it was close
to Easter so there's never enough time
and I always forget about it so last
year I put it on the list I wouldn't
forget so now reactive in time for
Easter
finally we tap into that lucrative
Easter Bunny did this get your reviews
do you know who is in it I think no idea
yeah we're really going into this blind
we have no idea that has a good
reputation bad reputation I know a lot
of people watch around Easter but I
don't yeah we're going to this totally
blind here we go up all right call it
you think the universal logos go ahead
yeah there it is it today okay
not since the Fox X in the exercise did
they do anything good besides despicable
means the war at thank you didn't they
do anything good besides Despicable Me
but great didn't they do anything good
okay I wanna know the movies behind all
these guys I don't know sure what I want
know these guys now ready look more
interesting probably than the main
character why oh I so hope he's the
bunny
I hope he has like tons of scream oh no
he's like the bunny and the human
version just to displease oh please dear
God now the scenes wasteful and you can
do something with that extra chocolate
why do I get the feeling this is just
gonna be the most interesting part
somebody has watched a lot of Silly
Symphonies okay I kind of love this part
now that's why I favorite part b-movie
to was showing like how they did all the
stuff in the high
really I love it
no I know I want to go into an animated
feature where that's whole second half
of movies at court oh my god I
absolutely loved it it's really odo for
no it's I don't know who they're movies
for that's certainly not for kids
what are you doing should I be afraid of
chicks well you are a nerd I am just so
distracted by that awesome bad I'm 37
and I want that bad so Fred hmm how'd
that job interview go
it went great it shut the up
o'clock you know this guy he just has
his life set cuz he always plays the dis
father doesn't he like he always plays
that ass Oh father
yes I'm sure she was a dick father in
that too you know sometimes I think you
adopted me because fred was such a
disappointment this is what kids want
sitting there listening to a family
argument about job interview right after
this magical Easter world and then it's
like go get a job kind of a tone change
man it's like every additional scene is
getting less and less good am i taking
it down I told you who the beginning was
any baggage just emotion no Russell
Brand we know that's true he's got the
perfect choice because he definitely
looks older but he has like such a young
teen face somehow but like it's like the
face is young but the rest of his head
is clearly a man sir want to know why he
was the perfect choice for this he said
yes I'm telling you that I am both a
bunny and incredibly sexy is a sad to
say now I'm hearing his voice I'm a poly
and incredibly sexy I can just see him
saying that on an interview Russell
Brand reminds me of that episode of The
Simpsons where Homer played the cop
never fear
I want a mystery I want salvation in the
secular age after the death of God we
look for salvation in love the one your
own personal Jesus and it's like he
thinks he's being awesome and everybody
around I figured it out you just haven't
yet everybody like what an asshole nice
to receive your bigotry from another
medium other than the hate rag mail on
Sunday from which normally total hatred
into the lid of your confinement button
down ya know it looks like reader rabbit
is trying to be hip with the younger
kids Harvey how did this film have such
a good opening three minutes like I was
legit oh my god there's a fetishistic
way it focused on that candy everything
went into this three minutes because
they knew they had to hook you quick and
then all of a sudden it was downhill
look for some baby ass no no you you say
that you you might run over baby you
know there's some grim imagery suggested
in this movie crushing the rabbit with a
rock adopting a kid whenever another kid
running over a baby but not have it fun
I love one yeah let's go needlessly dark
but none of this is in an amusing yet
knob is really smart or even like a what
the kind of way it's just boring
okay those are ridiculous a kid their
buddies I may not be cute by definition
no no there was a brand ones not very
cute point taken Irie tell you the worst
flight I ever had was Russell Brand on
it yes we were going to Los Angeles so
lax were the worst airports in the
country to begin with the only movie
they showed was Arthur oh I'm just like
well I'll give it a shot
I think I rather would have had the
plane crash remember when Lucy did this
like a hundred years ago okay
not a hundred years ago it was probably
close to like 75 remember this yeah like
that's really imaginative and cool I was
hoping to see more of it
but no put a flannel shirt off
bunny and we have a movie stupid
imagination thousand dumb idea
I'm not going like you're right this is
totally play as to a forgettable I am
legitimately a little angry that it
suckered me in that first few minutes I
actually thought maybe we were gonna get
something really creative and
imaginative Oh every scene just gets
less and less okay these things are kind
of kick in your naivete you believed
them I knew from the beginning I called
it you know again now there is about six
blind people in this band would you so
want to know more about their story than
this stupid bunny yeah don't pull that
with me rabbit okay I'm too smart for
you do you think he it like occurred to
him what kind of roller was when he had
to say don't pull that kind of thing
with me rabbit no it occurred to him
when he said so you poop candy so that's
what he's like I just got a dedicate
myself to it just gotta commit
yeah me too Senor the Sun is very
difficult to replace I can't tell if
this character is like a racist
stereotype or just plain awful
I just love thinking that we need a
crane shot how'd you like to just
directed this just like okay I guess I'm
doing a crane shot for a bunny talking
to a guy in a diner
it's not there he'll be animated later
for this an animated feature I mean what
are you gonna spend it on making the
bunny look realistic like he's actually
there a decent script so if he eats the
candy he shits out is that like Kevin
Costner drink his own piss from
Waterworld an idea cycling program does
he wear like a freman candy suit that
recycles everything like does off no
talent outside of Knight Rider I'm not
convinced they slit his throat
I was talking about they slit cyclopses
throw like those little dinosaurs of
lost where I'll be Justin Bieber yeah
yeah it's like so it's like two rabbits
basically bagged the bunny they're like
like throw a bag over said like drag
them off it's like hey where are you
going with my new friend then the third
just slits a super-sharp in the errant a
hose of fire hose of the saran wrap the
bunny you know like you one of the
little baskets and they forgot he came
free then they're just like yeah we
never liked them anyway we're in cahoots
with the chick then they just toss them
into the Los Angeles River which
hopefully is flooding at that point
it'll hide the body
Wow this movie missed us so we this was
really tired yeah man
I don't regret it how much footage is
there of just these two talking it's an
Easter Bunny movie and it's just these
two talking in a car then I don't know
you're the one who's the fan of the B
movie with Seinfeld and some chick and
then a court case at the end
laughs b-movie lame-o beginning I don't
get it I don't get how anyone can not
see the majesty can you not love that
movie thanks for ruining my big scene
asshole right I kind of feel bad for her
well she's doing it good yes sweet now
mr. Marsden we're paying you a lot of
money to hop on this ball over a hill
and fall over and act like you're having
the time of your life because you want
to be the Easter Bunny just say action
you can what take what they call me now
you're going to be talking to a giant
mexican chick that's sitting on your
knee and then Easter Bunny with a voice
of Hugh Laurie just say ax I will not
let you leave this room until you make
out with me
that's all I'm into rabbits too I get I
love the design of him though I love
that Brown as like Chris Lambert's brow
our son is dead
crashed in a giant egg let us honor him
by reminding us all then he was probably
adopted he's gone insane I'm off to star
in Oz the great and powerful yeah see
this is where I love to be flipping
through channels and then just come
across here and be like what the
was this total trash yeah man whose idea
was it's like now we're gonna have
people in it and shoot in LA and like
you could have just made it a
straight-up rip on arthur christmas and
it would have been better yeah honestly
him as an Easter Bunny that's a fun idea
like it's like the movie ends where it
should have started with him as the
bunny it's like I always have turned
into a bunny I want to see how he talks
with people maybe he can like you know
do like the business end to get other
candy companies and did that like
there's so many things you can do have
him learn about how it works and the
magic works and the animals like that
could be so funny they should have
called it I hop and he opens up a
pancake restaurant I go for it I mean go
for stupid jokes like that don't just
get the bunny flannel shirt and never
play the drums cool I don't hate it I
guess you know annoyed it's a perfectly
annoying movie I can't say I'm angry
like super frustrated noise so guys
that's about it um man yeah just big man
hop everybody just say action
you